[موسيقى]
جو بايدن مخترق سياسي فاسد وغير كفء
، ويمكنك إلقاء نظرة على
كل الأموال التي أخذها من
دول أجنبية وغيرها الكثير من
خلال ابنه هانتر الذي هو
مدمن مخدرات فاسد ومنفذ
لوالده.  مدعي خاص بالمناسبة
[موسيقى]
هذا الاستغلال الرهيب للسلطة هو
الأحدث في سلسلة طويلة من مطاردة الساحرات
والتي بدأت منذ وقت طويل هذه
صفقة حفار تمامًا كما تم تزوير انتخابات 2020
ولا يمكننا السماح
لا يمكننا أن نفعل ذلك ، لا يمكننا السماح
بحدوث ذلك لبلدنا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
لقد كنت أقوم بهذه
التحقيقات والخدع والخدع
من  في اليوم الذي نزلت فيه المصعد في
برج ترامب
، ستقول حقًا إنه يكفي
للعودة إلى العمل ، فلدي إثبات أن
لدينا بلدًا رائعًا مرة أخرى
لأنه الآن ليس رائعًا في الوقت الحالي ، إنه
مخزون مضحك في جميع أنحاء العالم.